as a man as you or me  that  that party time it's not going to be  forever exactly we settle mate fair  enough we settle can I add something and  then uh like from my own experience I  came to this country when I was younger  right from where from Senegal okay uh I  did I've did a lot of stuff right I've  I've did crazy stuff but when it was  time for me to get married I went back  home with Senegal I went back to Senegal  I found the right woman for me because I  knew what I saw from what I saw in this  country there's no chance for the women  in the school for the women in this  country there was no you wouldn't marry  a woman no Audrey no oh there's there's  one percent chance right okay because  I'm not saying every woman that I meet  in the city on Friday night or Saturday  night all the same yeah